Hans sapai im fragenlotte und da geht es
natürlich um solche Fragen wie braucht
er den Hype weil er als Fußballer nicht
mehr den Erfolg hat oder wer braucht
diesen Hype überhaupt also fragen über
Fragen jetzt im Fragenlotto mit Hans
saai weißt du was das ist nee weiß ich
nicht was ist das denn kann ich was
gewinnen kannst du morgen im Express
lesen kann ich was gewinnen was nee du
kannst auch nichts gewinnen ne du kannst
doch du kannst also du oder jemand
anders kann was gewinnen nein nee du
hast dich wahrscheinlich immer gefragt
welche gemeinen Fragen sind mir noch nie
gestellt worden und die sind hier drin
pass auf und zwar die roten sind total
gemeine Fragen das ist unser fragenung
die grün Grünen sind total harmlose
Fragen du kannst dich entscheiden also
kann ich grün ziehen du kannst grün
ziehen oder auch rot ziehen oder
blindziehen eine
eine manche wollen alle beantworten ja
wieso so zwei drei schon und dann gucken
wir das ist wie viel Grüne sind da drin
vier und vier du willst wirklich nur
grüne das vier und vier oder so ungefähr
ja so ungefähr ah ich gucke nicht du
guckst nicht das ist schön ah eine
grüne genau einfach
abdrehen also sind fein sisiliert extra
auf dich zugeschnitten diese
Fragen wir haben uns wie immer große
Mühe
gegeben gibt es etwas was hansp nicht
kann das haben wir ja schon beantwortet
ja aber das war das Interview also gibt
es son sonst es gibt etwas ich kann mich
nicht ich kann die Zeit nicht anhalten
okay oder mich zurückbeamen dass ich wie
z.B mich zurückbiben würde zu der WM wo
wir im Viertelfinale gegen ja
Uruguay leider verloren haben oder ich
würde mich zurückbieben D
dass dass Schalke die Spiele alle
gewinnt okay und wir noch dieses Jahr
Deutscher Meister werden das aber sieht
schlecht aus ja das leider sieht ja
selbst für München schlecht aus ja das
ist das ist München ihre
Sache eine rote
sensationell brauchst du den Erfolg auf
Facebook weil du als Fußballer nicht so
viel so viele Titel gewonnen
hast und ja
erstmal habe ich ja nicht auf Facebook
irgendwas angeleiert Erfolg zu haben das
das habt keine Ahnung die ihr da draußen
ihr draußen gemacht und ich bin
eigentlich auf dem Zug dann
aufgesprungen hab gebe füttere euch
damit ihr noch mehr lacht damit es
witzig ist und bleibt also die Folgen
auf Twitter und auf facebook Fan werden
dann hat man viel zu lachen sowieso
deswegen immer wieder auf meine Seite da
passiert da wird noch einiges passieren
okay kann man jetzt noch nicht sagen
aber werdet ihr alles sehen du hast doch
Zukunftspläne und
ähm und und Titel gewonnen ich
glaube ja ich habe ich bin nur mit sch
jetzt
Pokalsieger geworden aber ich glaube es
werden viele Fußballer
froh zwei WMS gespielt zu haben dreimal
Afrika Cup und Champions League Spiel
und deswegen glaube ich schon ich habe
schon einiges erreicht du h ja unter
anderem auch ja ein Verein gewählt wo es
ja ganz klar ist dass man nicht gewinnen
kann wer in fzekusen spielt der weiß
ja da wird nie was kommen ja das kann
sein aber das ist ja immer das Schöne
daran wenn du dann bei so einem Verein
bist und dann doch vielleicht was
erreicht wir waren da auch im Finale im
DFB Pokal und haben es nicht geschafft
hätte wei man deswegen
aber ist es nicht trotzdem ein schöner
schönes Gefühl diese Prominenz erreicht
zu haben obwohl man eben kaum was im
keine Titel gewonnen hat außer ich meine
dabei sein ist natürlich alles aber
trotzdem ja natürlich doch es ist es ist
doch schön deswegen wenn es nicht schön
wäre würde ich das ja gar nicht machen
es ist deswegen auch hier zu sein ist
schön hier mit euch zu sein zu sprechen
und und diese lustigen Sachen zu
machen wie gesagt solange es nicht schön
witzig es muss immer witzig sein dann
kann man mich für vieles haben okay gut
also für eine Frage noch komm eine noch
oder zwei oder
drei die roten sind die
schönsten wär es nicht besser Chuck
Norris als Fußballer
geworden boah nee eigentlich nicht
Fußballer ist glaube
ich finde ich das schönste und das Beste
was mir passieren konnte ist das was man
als Kind mit Freunden draußen auf der
Straße gespielt hat und selber im
Fernsehen die Leute dort der Bundesliga
bejubelt hat und dann steht man
irgendwann selber da und die ganzen Fans
jubeln einen zu und dann ist schon ein
Kind raum wahr geworden ch no macht ja
natürlich macht Filme und aber dahin
habe ich nie mich irgendwie
spezialisiert oder hingeahnt oder
versucht irgendein Schauspieler zu
werden deswegen ist ist schon gut dass
es so gekommen ist dass ich für Fußball
Fußballer geworden bin für die Vereine
die ich gespielt habe Wolfsburg
Leverkusen Schalke spielen zu dürfen und
das und zw und der Nationalmannschaft
man kommt ja viel rum auch dabei und
lernt viele Leute auch kennen Fußball
ein Traumberuf
ja das ist glaube ich was so viele
Kinder auf die draußen spielen das gerne
werden wollen es ist ein traumberuft
aber man sollte wissen da gibt's sind
sind auch viele negative Sachen mit im
behalten okay komm noch eine mal gucken
ob sie grün oder rot
wird das tut mir so
leid wer braucht eigentlich diesen
unsinnigen Hype um Hans
sapai das ist eine gute Frage ja wer
braucht
ihn ich
ihr also kommt auf meine Seite schaut
euch das an ob es euch gefällt oder
nicht dann könnt ihr selber
entscheiden
wunderbar genau das ich danke dir
vielmals bei Klick sensationell vielen
Dank ich danke auch und ich kann euch
noch das Fragen und ab die empfehlen
indem sie erklären warum in der
Musikbranche Zustände wie im Swingerclub
herrschen also wenn euch das
interessiert da drauf klicken und wenn
euch das mit Fahrt interessiert äh indem
er erklärt welche Drogen er niemals
nehmen würde dann klickt auf das Video
das Fragenlotto mit Fahrt und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt
dran